three two one three two one great all
right first time if you guys like it
because I want to make sure that you
guys actually like the photo
Courtney Cox makes a friends fan Cry
tears of joy I thought it was incredible
the actress who starred as Monica Geller
in the hit series photobombed fans who
were touring the Warner Brothers lot and
stopped at the iconic Fountain where the
intro of friends was filmed it was just
the best opportunity on the best show
and I was I was really lucky to be a
part and become friends and work with
all of his incredible people the same
lot where Courtney's filming her latest
project shining Veil on stage five which
is where friends started is where the
attic is of of you know yeah my
characters where she writes and where
Rosemary visits her and so yeah it's
it's it's great yeah and Courtney's
giving these friends aficionados a great
gift they'll never forget I'm working at
Warner Brothers and I thought this is a
good time for me to surprise some
friends fans and photobomb their shots
it all went down on Wednesday when the
actress snuck behind the nostalgic
orange couch where fans were taking
pictures all right ready three two one
three two one and then there's the big
reveal all right first time if you guys
like it because I want to make sure that
you guys actually like the photo
can you tell me that's good
is that a good photo
no you're playing with me
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm really honored I'm excited to meet
everybody on Instagram Courtney
captioned the photo don't you hate a
photo bomber it's one of my favorite
jobs for sure
[Applause]
two one I'm sorry we're taking a photo
do you mind
[Music]